la visite décidément mouvementée
d'Emmanuel Macron au Pays-Bas après un
discours interrompu hier par des
manifestants qui lui reprochaient son
autoritarisme un homme a tenté de
l'approcher en fin de matinée à
Amsterdam il a été plaqué au sol par des
agents de sécurité le manifestant
chantait on est là on est là un hymne
anti Macron qui est en fait celui des
gilets jaunes très repris dans les
cortèges contre la réforme des retraites
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à Amsterdam le roi s'est exprimé en
français bon épouse et moi mais
attendons votre visite avec impatience
une visite printemps alors que les
arbres reverdissent du coup le président
français s'est mis au néerlandais juste
avant l'arrivée des officiels il y avait
de l'ambiance trop visiblement pour une
personne présente dans la salle qui a
poussé une gueulante mais alors une
gueulante ne disposant pas de traducteur
néerlandais en un sous-titré à l'oreille
[Musique]
quand même parce que le pain surprise
était délicieux
alors pour savoir comment il parle
néerlandais il suffit de regarder le
monsieur du protocole derrière en haut à
droite on va zoomer sur lui
le couple Macron qui continue sa visite
au Pays-Bas hier le président a été hué
lors d'un discours donné à la haie par
des jeunes manifestants oui des jeunes
sont rentrés dans la haie par surprise
normalement c'est l'inverse
et
pardon et ils ont interpellé Emmanuel
Macron sur la réforme des stress
on a perdu menu je crois je suis désolé
on a perdu Emmanuel
il va revenir
[Rires]
alors on a trouvé ça un peu méchant car
on aimerait bien l'entendre parler
français le monsieur le Président
français également du langage fleuri de
Donald Trump il a tout simplement accusé
Emmanuel Macron de je cite lécher le cul
du président chinois une réaction aux
propos d'Emmanuel Macron qui avait
demandé à ne pas être suivi cette des
États-Unis sur le dossier de Taïwan
Donald Trump accuse Emmanuel Macron de
lécher les bottes du Président si
jimping mais alors non non je ne crois
pas que ce soit la véritable citation
il est avec la Chine en train de lui
lécher etc voilà c'est pas ça la vraie
citation ça vient de Trump qui qui on le
sait était élégant
Macron qui est un ami qui est avec la
Chine en train de lui lécher
alors on a bipé kissing my home qui
signe
Emmanuel Macron je cite de lécher le cul
du président
allez c'est parti
lécher le cul du président chinois
lécher le cul lécher le cul lécher le
cul il est chez le cul lol
c'est cette série qui cartonne sur
Amazon le principe c'est grosso modo à
Loft et la règle c'est que si on rit on
sort et vous me faites penser à Paul
mirabelle Paul mirabelle c'est cette
humoriste qui ne fait rien c'est-à-dire
pendant toute la série il est
passe-partout il fait de temps en temps
une petite pitchenette pour faire tomber
un adversaire et sinon il le prend aucun
risque et ça marche et ça marche parce
qu'il arrive en finale
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est ça votre stratégie
c'est pas très glorieux mais c'est
peut-être ça votre stratégie pas faire
grand chose quoi mais je ne vous
autorise pas à dire cela car c'est
totalement faux c'est ce qu'a écrit un
certain nombre de journalistes mais
c'est un mensonge la réalité c'est que
nous en fait tout ce qui était dans
notre pouvoir pour lutter contre cette
réforme des retraites qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la retraite à 60 ans
que tout le monde y soit pour profiter
un petit peu parce que quand on a
travaillé 40 ans 45 ans bah vous savez
on a besoin de repos Dominique
Strauss-Kahn donne son avis sur la
retraite via Twitter demain je
Strauss-Kahn fustige le timing la
méthode la stratégie et le 49-3 ce qu'il
appelle les quatre erreurs d'Emmanuel
Macron il paraît que Dominique
Strauss-Kahn est très intelligent s'il
était à ce point il comprendrait que
tout le monde se fiche de son avis il
devrait se taire jusqu'à la fin de sa
vie et profiter du grand air frais de la
liberté Gérard Depardieu visé par de
nouvelles accusations de violences
sexuelles ces Mediapart qui a mené
l'enquête et recueilli le témoignage de
13 femmes qui évoquent des propos et des
gestes déplacés sur des tournages entre
2004 et 2022 actrice maquilleuse ou
technicienne a dénonce des paroles
obscènes et parfois des gestes qui le
sont également selon ses avocats
l'acteur dément l'ensemble des
accusations
comédienne sur la série Netflix
Marseille évoque elle aussi des scènes
d'agression sexuelle je dis tout fort il
y a GG qui me met sa main dans mon short
il a répondu bah quoi je pensais que tu
voulais réussir dans le cinéma tout le
monde arrive du coup il a continué
aucune nouvelle plainte n'a été déposée
ces femmes ayant le sentiment
d'après-midi parc que leurs paroles
pèserait peu face à ce monument du
cinéma français à l'époque vous rendiez
compte de la résonance alors en effet
vous avez une un rapport sexuel avec
l'autre pour ceux qui ne se souviennent
pas
c'est une légende urbaine en fait peu
importe en tout cas alors pas dans la
piscine enfin en gros il s'est passé
quelque chose devant la caméra ça avait
attisé évidemment ça avait complètement
fasciné c'est la première fois qu'on
voyait ce genre de scène on va dire en
réalité
alors on devine
vous rendiez compte que ça allait
marquer les esprits à ce point-là
moi je tiens à le rappeler l'émission
quand j'ai passé le casting je pensais
qu'elle durait un soir
je faisais on faisait pas ça pour
l'argent quand je dis qu'aujourd'hui les
réseaux sociaux ont tué le jeu en
flingué le Game j'aime bien dire ça mais
c'est que aujourd'hui les gens font tout
par intérêt moi c'était pas pour vendre
des crèmes amincissantes sur Instagram
c'est pour vous amuser une expérience
j'ai gagné 20000 francs sur 80 jours
c'est dire c'est mal parti pour cet
enfant devient un jour caissier
[Rires]